these border guards aren't preparing to
shield ukraine from a russian invasion
instead they're practicing what to do if
belarus sends migrants their way
it's a move officials fear could be used
as a distraction or a provocation at a
time of mounting concern that russia is
planning a large-scale attack
inside
but this isn't just regular warfare with
tanks and guns
ukraine's armed forces are having to
operate in a very gray zone where
anything including migrants can be used
as a weapon against them
belarus is less than a mile down the
road it's a country closely allied with
russia and the worry is any provocation
along the border however small could be
the spark that ignites a much wider
conflict between russia and ukraine
fake news allegedly linked to russia is
a key ingredient
this video spread on social media claims
to show ukrainian border guards firing
on migrants crossing from belarus
this was not true there were no nobody
suffered the information minister says
ukraine published a rebuttal one of many
used to fight back against what he says
is a rising tide of false claims by
russia why they're using this
disinformation is to
bring a legitimate legitimacy
to what they're doing physically towards
their doing on the international arena
to what they're trying to do
threatening in ukraine or grabbing our
territory putin
says ukraine is anti-russia it's an
information war that keeps journalists
and activists like aleona busy she uses
videos and a website to debunk what she
describes as russian fakes right up to
an essay on ukraine written by president
vladimir putin
130 manipulations and
105 fakes on that article
an increasingly murky gray zone that
could get morph into a war zone
debra haynes sky news on the ukraine
belarus border